bonjour à tous mardi dernier
dessinateurs ont adopté une proposition
de loi socialiste qui vise à limiter
l'utilisation des techniques
biométriques à toute nécessité de
sécurité ces techniques qu'elles
sont-elles ce sont des techniques qui
utilisent la reconnaissance par le corps
reconnaissance par l'iris ou encore
empreinte digitale ce sont des
techniques qui sont déjà utilisées pour
les pièces identité pour les passeports
mais voilà Gaëtan Gorce a constaté de
nombreuses excès en la matière l'auteur
de cette proposition de loi dénonce par
exemple et bien ces reconnaissances par
les mains pour des enfants enfin qu'ils
puissent accéder à des cantines ou
encore à des piscines reconnaissances
également du corps pour des personnes
afin qu'elles accèdent aux locaux dans
lesquels elle travaille alors même qu'il
n'y a pas de nécessité de sécurité
particulière c'est pour lutter contre
ces excès que gaétankorse a déposé ce
texte un texte philosophique juridique
éthique qui veut se garantir de toute
instrumentalisation du corps tout de
suite donc retour par la séance c'était
mardi après-midi au Sénat
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à Monsieur gate en Gorce auteur de
la proposition de loi
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
pourquoi présenter une proposition de
loi visant à limiter la biométrie aux
finalité de sécurité pourquoi donner le
sentiment de vouloir s'opposer à cette
évolution inéluctable que l'on appelle
aujourd'hui encore le progrès pourquoi
vouloir privé nos concitoyens de la
possibilité
d'ouvrir leur smartphone en utilisant la
reconnaissance faciale d'accéder à un
équipement public en utilisant la
reconnaissance du contour de la main
bref comme le reprochait l'autre jour
une personnalité intervenant dans le
cadre du débat qui avait organisé forte
fortunément monsieur le président de la
commission des lois pourquoi donc créer
ces difficultés en obligeant chacun à
continuer à mémoriser un code utiliser
une carte éventuellement acheter un
ticket
je n'oublie pas que ces questions
soulèvent évidemment de gros enjeux qui
sont économiques qui sont industriels
qui sont technologiques et je ne propose
pas d'aborder non plus ce sujet
uniquement par le biais de la protection
des libertés individuelles même si
naturellement sur ce terrain beaucoup
d'observations forment légitimes sont
régulièrement faites qui insistent par
exemple sur les risques
d'interopérabilité des différents
systèmes qui pourraient conduire à un
système de mise sous profil de
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens je
n'oublie pas non plus que nous avons
affaire à une réglementation qui reste
extrêmement rigoureuse puisque sous le
l'empire de la loi de 78 modifiée en
2004 c'est le régime d'autorisation qui
prévaut toujours aujourd'hui pour mettre
en place de telles traitements de
données biométriques je n'oublie pas
enfin les travaux qui ont été menés par
le Parlement et notamment par cet
assemblée sous la responsabilité en
particulier de Jean-René le cerf mais si
j'ai suggéré à travers cette proposition
reprise par le groupe socialiste
d'aborder la question des traitements de
données biométriques c'est qu'il me
semble que trois problèmes devaient être
à mon sens absolument débattus dans nos
assemblées le premier à trait à
l'ampleur du changement technologique
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
naturellement l'innovation n'est pas par
définition anthonien j'allais dire
presque paradoxalement nouvelle elle
rythme nos économies depuis plus de deux
siècles depuis notamment la révolution
industrielle mais elle prend aujourd'hui
une dimension et surtout un rythme qui
n'a plus rien à voir avec ce que nous
connaissions auparavant lorsque la
machine à vapeur s'est mise en place ou
lorsqu'on a pu développer la machine à
tisser elle s'est installée dans nos
modes de production et à la modifié la
façon de vivre et de travailler de nos
concitoyens au long des décennies
lorsque c'est opéré la révolution de
l'électricité cela a été un peu plus
rapide mais au fond à l'échelle au moins
d'une vie entière ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui notamment avec la révolution
numérique c'est que le changement
technologique se perd à une vitesse qui
rend obsolète toutes les habitudes les
pratiques et les usages auxquels dans
une vie même nous pouvions être habitués
les chiffres que l'on observe en la
matière sont spectaculaire on considère
par exemple qu'au rythme des innovations
observées en 2000 il aurait fallu
simplement 20 ans pour réaliser
l'ensemble des innovations qui ont été
constatées tout au long du 20e siècle et
que si ce rythme était maintenu tout au
long du 21e on pourrait réaliser en
moins d'un siècle la totalité des
innovations réalisées par l'humanité
depuis que la civilisation s'est
organisée c'est dire la vitesse à
laquelle le changement est en train de
s'opérer et que nous pouvons parfois
avoir le sentiment d'être moins à
l'initiative du changement que d'une
certaine manière produit par lui et que
la créature ou que les créatures que
pourraient produire cette technologie
sont en train de nous échapper ce qui
pose évidemment la question de la
démocratie puisque si le changement
n'est plus le fait de la volonté
politique mais d'un mouvement qui lui
échappe dans lequel est intégré la
question de savoir quelle société nous
on prend évidemment des caractéristiques
nouvelles et différentes c'est la raison
pour laquelle il m'a semblé qu'il était
indispensable sur cette question
particulière mais on ouvrant un débat
plus large nous puissions nous
interroger sur ces évolutions la
deuxième raison qui m'a conduit à
déposer ce texte c'est une raison qui
tient cette fois non pas à l'ampleur du
changement mais à sa nature jusqu'à
présent le changement technique
technologique que l'innovation avait
surtout concerné les organisations
depuis maintenant quelques décennies
elle touche à la personne elle-même
certes la révolution numérique a touché
à des sujets qui intéressent la
personnalité dans ces éléments les plus
essentiels à commencer par la
connaissance elle traite des données qui
touchent à sa vie quotidienne à son
travail à ses loisirs aux recherches qui
le perd pour effectuer des acquisitions
commerciales mais aussi aux relations
que la personne entretient avec ses
proches ou avec ses amis toute son
donnée toutes ces données font l'objet
de traitement de plus en plus rapide de
plus en plus poussés à des fins
commerciales selon nous pouvons discuter
parfois à des fins de Rense et de police
ce que l'affaire stoden nous a révélé et
avec le traitement des données
biométriques ce sont des données qui
touchent à la personne elle-même le
corps physique son intégrité qui sont
désormais mise en question et ce débat
mais cette évolution me semble-t-il
mérite une discussion
d'autant plus que le cadre juridique
dans lequel ce changement se perd me
paraît nécessaire ne paraît mal ajusté
lorsque l'on regarde comme on les choses
aujourd'hui sont prises en compte on
s'aperçoit que peu de protection en
réalité sont mises en place j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure la loi de 1978 et le
règlement et la loi de 2004 avec la
perspective du règlement européen mais
rien d'encadre les conditions dans
lequel la CNIL est amené à autoriser les
traitements biométriques les critères
sont laissés à sa seule appréciation ce
qui conduit la CNIL aujourd'hui a
autorisé des traitements biométriques
non plus simplement dit de sécurité mais
de confort comme par exemple la
reconnaissance du contour de la main
pour accepter à une cant scolaire ou
accéder à un équipement sportif ce qui
banalise indiscutablement le recours à
la biométrie et crée une situation
nouvelle à cela s'ajoute le fait que à
plusieurs reprises le Conseil
constitutionnel a été appelé à refuser
aux données biométriques une protection
équivalente mais c'est vrai aussi pour
le Conseil d'État à celle qui protège le
corps humain l'inviolabilité et
l'indisponibilité ne s'applique pas pour
l'instant à ces données or comme je l'ai
indiqué ces données touche à l'intimité
de la personne et leur utilisation et
leur recours pose un problème me
semble-t-il extrêmement important qui
n'est pas simplement juridique ou
économique et philosophique qui est
celui de l'objectivation de la personne
dans quelles conditions peut-on accepter
que des éléments qui sont directement
liés à la personne puisse être ainsi
utilisés et traiter qu'est-ce qui nous
paraît justifier le type de recours à ce
type de données ne peut-on pas
considérer qu'il y a si la banalisation
devait s'installer risque de finalement
mesurer la personne uniquement au regard
de cette appréciation mesurable
numérisable comme si au fond ne comptait
plus n'ont pas la valeur ou
l'appréciation personnelle mais la
mesure que l'on peut donc faire c'est à
dire au fond une logique qui devient
purement économique ou ce qu'on aurait
pu appeler autrefois une rationalité sur
le bon des philosophes purement
instrumental et ce qu'il n'y a pas là le
risque d'un changement profond de notre
société ce sont toutes ces questions que
je souhaitais aborder à travers le texte
qui a été déposé sans avoir le sentiment
d'avoir une solution à une réponse
totalement satisfaisante mais en
revanche avec la conviction que ce débat
devait se tenir dans nos assemblées dont
il a d'implication je l'ai indiqué pas
seulement sur le plan économique et
juridique mais aussi sur le plan
philosophique la proposition qui vous
est présentée se contente donc
aujourd'hui non pas de traiter des
questions comme par exemple le
développement de la biométrie je le
regrette presque mais il s'agit d'ouvrir
le débat comme le développement de la
biométrie dans le cadre de relation
contractuelles qui sont celles qui
unissent l'utilisateur d'un outil
numérique à la société qui ne lui
propose par exemple vous avez vu la
volonté d'Apple de développer récemment
un nouveau type de téléphone auquel on
peut accéder en utilisant
l'empreinte digitale n'a pas connu un
grand succès mais c'est un élément
nouveau on sait que Facebook par exemple
est en train de travailler sur un
système de reconnaissance faciale qui
n'a pas là pour objet de faciliter
l'activité des utilisateurs de Facebook
mais d'améliorer le profilage en
essayant de repérer quels sont quels
sont les humeurs au moment où la
personne est en train d'entrer une
information de passer une commande
est-ce que c'est un achat d'impulsion
est-ce que ça n'acha réfléchi est-ce que
ça n'achète colérique est-ce que c'est
un achat qui traduit au fond une
impatience et un monde bref tous ces
éléments aujourd'hui intéressent ces
grandes sociétés qui sont en train par
conséquent de transformer ce qui est
notre vie même c'est-à-dire le droit qui
est le nôtre me semble-t-il à hésiter
notre à l'imprécision même le droit à
l'erreur le droit à l'errance le droit
aux secrets à vouloir pénétrer dans ces
éléments pour en faire un élément de
politique commerciale ces sujets
méritent donc d'être discutés la
proposition que je vous présente ne vise
pas à régler ces questions de relation
contractuelles encore que cela
mériterait discussion mais simplement à
indiquer aujourd'hui comme un butoir que
nous pourrions installer à indiquer que
lorsque l'on souhaite développer un
traitement de données biométriques on
doit pouvoir le faire que lorsqu'il y a
une exigence majeure de sécurité
concernant la nature du site que l'on
veut protéger la nature des personnes
qui s'y trouvent ou la nature des
informations qui sont concernées à
l'intérêt qui doit dépasser le pur
intérêt commercial et qui doit
représenter une préoccupation plus large
c'est ce que rappellera tout à l'heure
j'en suis sûr notre rapporteur et qui
tentera à préciser par un amendement les
éléments qui figurent dans ce texte
voilà mes chers collègues à la fois la
motivation qui est la mienne tout en
sachant évidemment que en entrant sur ce
terrain nous nous exposons à des
critiques très vives puisqu'on peut
donner le sentiment de vouloir s'opposer
comme je l'ai indiqué à la marche
inéluctable du progrès j'ai pourtant le
sentiment qu'on le faisons nous sommes
dans la tradition de notre haut
assemblée qui consiste à tenter
d'examiner les questions de fond avec
patience et impartialité en rappelant
notre société qu'elle n'est pas la
simplement pour répondre à des modes ou
à la loi du marché mais pour rappeler
des valeurs auxquelles elle reste
attachée
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur François pilier rapporteur de
la commission des lois
ce Président Madame ministre mes chers
collègues parce que la biométrie
embrasse l'ensemble des procédés qui
identifient un individu à partir de la
mesure de l'une ou de plusieurs de ses
caractéristiques physiques
physiologiques voire comportementale
parce que produite par le corps la
donnée biométrique le désigne ou le
représente de façon immuable parce que
ces données concernent la propriété la
plus proche de l'immatérialité de chaque
être parce que les catégories classant
ces techniques évoluent ainsi il en est
ainsi des
traces des données dites traçantes avec
la multiplication des engins vidéos qui
placent désormais la reconnaissance
faciale dans les techniques traçantes
qui n'étaient pas le cas au départ parce
que ces évolutions peuvent inquiéter la
réflexion à laquelle nous invite Gaëtan
Gorce est particulièrement opportun
le Sénat doit se donner une doctrine sur
l'usage et la conservation des données
biométriques dans la perspective de
l'examen prochain du projet de loi sur
les libertés numériques à l'initiative
de la CNIL le législateur a soumis par
la loi du 6 août 2004 le traitement des
données biométriques un régime
d'autorisation préalable afin d’ailleurs
de faciliter le travail de la CNIL
l'article 25 prévoit que les traitements
identiques peuvent être autorisés par
une décision unique cela concerne par
exemple la reconnaissance par le contour
de la main pour l'accès un restaurant
scolaire la France c'est ainsi dotée de
l'un des régimes les plus protecteurs en
la matière mais sans que le législateur
se soit prononcé quant à la pertinence
des différents usages des techniques
biométriques laissant à la CNIL toute
latitude pourrait élaborer une doctrine
or cette dernière est en cours
d'évolution comme pour toute autre
autorisation l'examen par la CNIL
consiste en l'analyse de la
proportionnalité eu égard à la finalité
envisagée de 2005 à 2012 la CNIL a
distingué les techniques biométriques
Atlas susceptibles d'être capturé à
l'insu de la personne des techniques
centrales comme le contour de la main la
reconnaissance vocale le réseau veineux
du droit ou l'iris et à partir de 2013
elle a pris conscience de la faiblesse
de cette classification est engagé une
réflexion engageant trois cas le premier
cas la biométrie de sécurité
indispensable pour répondre à une
contrainte de sécurité physique ou
logique d'un organisme imposé à des
utilisateurs ceci doivent cependant être
informés des conditions d'utilisation du
dispositif on peut penser à des exemples
comme celui protégeant l'accès à l'île
Longue
deuxième cas la biométrie de services ou
de confort reposant sur le libre
consentement de l'usager celui-ci se
voit proposer sans contrainte ni sur
coup un dispositif alternatif et puis
enfin troisième cas les expérimentations
c'est à dire les travaux de recherche
fondamentale menés par les laboratoires
ou le test de dispositif avant leur
implémentation éventuelle adaptant ces
exigences aux finalités de chaque
traitement la CNIL ne s'autorise pas à
juger de leur pertinence or
l'utilisation de la biométrie se
banalise et se répand dans tous les
domaines de la vie quotidienne notamment
pour sécuriser les transactions
financières la proposition de loi que
nous examinons aujourd'hui peut faire
office de première pierre à la
construction de la réflexion sénatoriale
est encore s'interroge sur la légitimité
de certains usages comme celui
déterminant l'accès dans les cantines
scolaires sécurisante par ce ergonomie
la biométrie de confort mais il est vrai
guerre rassurant quant à la valeur du
consentement des usagers les parents
ont-ils vraiment le choix de refuser
l'application de cette technique pour
les enfants qui fréquentent les cantines
l'exposé des motifs invite à penser un
statut spécifique pour les données
biométriques qui ne peuvent bénéficier
de la protection de l'article 16-1 du
Code civil le dispositif de la
proposition de loi complète l'article 25
de la loi du 6 janvier 1978 qui soumet à
autorisation de la CNIL les traitements
non-étatiques les traitements mis en
oeuvre pour le compte de l'État serait
effectivement ainsi
exclu du champ de la proposition de loi
qui n'encadrerait que le pouvoir de la
CNIL et non le pouvoir réglementaires à
ce propos je vous rappelle d'ailleurs
que le Conseil constitutionnel par sa
censure partielle de la loi de 2012
relative à la protection de l'identité
n'a pas interdit l'usage de la biométrie
mais seulement la portée de certains
fichiers
la proposition de loi ne définit pas un
statut de la donnée biométrique mais
elle conditionne l'autorisation de son
traitement par la CNIL a je cite une
stricte nécessité de sécurité cette
formule pose problème nos y reviendrons
ne sont pas incluses dans le champ de la
proposition de loi les activités
exclusivement personnelles comme
l'ouverture de cession sur les nouveaux
iPhone par reconnaissance digitale ou de
visage cela mériterait pourtant je
l'estime que l'on s'interroge quant aux
effets du texte proposé sur les
dispositifs existants la CNIL estime
ajuste raison que toutes les
autorisations délivrées jusqu'à présent
ne seraient pas reconduites et que sa
nouvelle doctrine ne pourrait être
conservée enfin la proposition autorise
implicitement les expérimentations le
problème
fondamental et le rôle que nous voulons
jouer
en 2004 le législateur n'a pas saisi
l'occasion de se prononcer sur les
usages légitimes de la biométrie
j'estime que ce rôle lui revient et
qu'il ne peut pas le laisser un
organisme comme la CNIL si sérieux
soit-il or le gouvernement devrait
déposer un projet de loi sur les
libertés numériques le Conseil de
l'Europe s'apprête à réaliser la
Convention pour la protection des
personnes à l'égard du traitement
automatisé des données à caractère
personnel dites convention 108 son
article 6 inviterait le législateur à
encadré le traitement des données
biométriques je partage l'objectif de
promouvoir un usage raisonné des
techniques biométriques sous quelques
réserves il faut que notre décision soit
cohérente avec le règlement européen à
venir sur la protection des données à
caractère personnel qui sera
d'application directe
toute contrainte a priori serait
supprimée au bénéfice d'un contrôle
apostériori renforcé la résolution
législative du Parlement européen du 12
mars 2014 interdit le traitement des
données biométriques en prévoyant des
exceptions en particulier si la personne
y a consenti à moins qu'une disposition
nutritionnelle il fasse obstacle la
notion de stricte nécessité de sécurité
assemblé insuffisamment précise à de
nombreuses personnes entendues lors des
auditions je suggère qu'elle soit
précisée et entendu de façon nitrolaque
ni trop étroite ce qui pourrait être
productif puisqu'elle inciterait les
acteurs acheter des services à
l'étranger échappant à la loi française
la notion d'intérêt excédant l'intérêt
propre de l'organisme introduite par une
communication de la CNIL datant de 2007
pourrait certainement y était enfin pour
éviter que certaines dispositions se
trouvent hors la loi un dispositif
transitoire est nécessaire cette
proposition de loi ouvre donc un débat
utile sur un patrimoine humain qui doit
être protégé le Sénat doit se forger une
opinion sur la question et affirmer que
l'on ne peut faire n'importe quel usage
des données biométriques même pour des
raisons de confort Jean-Pierre
maintenant au texte de la commission des
lois
à mon initiative celle-ci a adopté deux
amendements prenons d'abord le second
qui crée un article 2 qui ne pose aucune
difficulté puisqu'il prévoit un
dispositif transitoire afin d'accorder
un délai de trois ans au responsable de
traitement pour se mettre en conformité
avec la nouvelle législation en revanche
le premier qui réécrit l'article premier
suscite des interrogations hésitations
une critique a été émise à l'encontre de
l'imprécision des deux expressions
enjeux majeures dépassant l'intérêt
stricte de l'organisme et deuxième
expression préjudice grave et réversible
je vais donc m'arrêter un instant sur
chacune d'entre elles à ce fin
d'expliquer mon intention de façon à ce
que nous puissions débattre sereinement
première condition première expression
enjeux majeur dépassant l'intérêt strict
de l'organisme ce qui motive cette
expression et la volonté de proclamer
ici la nature particulière des données
biométriques et d'affirmer que leur
utilisation loin d'être doit poursuivre
un intérêt en quelque sorte supérieur si
la société accepte soit utilisée ce type
de données c'est à la condition qu'elle
y trouve son compte soit en tant que
collectivité soit au travers de chacun
de nous cette expression peut recouvrir
en particulier le cas d'usage de la
biométrie dans la sécurisation des
transactions financières car au-delà
même de l'intérêt de la banque et du
commerçant il en va bien de l'intérêt
même des citoyens consommateurs cela
étant dit nous verrons à l'occasion de
la discussion que la rédaction de cette
condition peut être amendée en revanche
issu en quelque sorte de la
jurisprudence de la CNIL il ne peut lui
être adressé le grief d'imprécision
comment pourrait-on prétendre qu'il y a
ici un risque d'insécurité juridique
alors même que nous disposons du corpus
des délibérations de la CNIL pour nous
assister dans son interprétation
j'invite ce dont le doute persisterait à
consulter la communication de la CNIL en
date du 28 décembre 2007 celle-ci nous
fournit notamment de nombreux exemples
de dispositifs autorisés car entrant
dans le cadre d'un je cite la formule
qui n'est pas de moi en jeu majeur
dépassant l'intérêt de l'organisme la
protection par exemple d'installation
nucléaire de sites classes et ses
vaisseaux d'entreprises travaillant pour
la défense nationale de salle contenant
des informations confidentielles
défentes et même d'un service de
l'éducation nationale contenant les
sujets d'examen et de concours répond à
cette définition et cette condition
deuxième condition et deuxième
expression préjudice grave et
irréversible cette expression est issue
de l'exposé des motifs de la proposition
de loi de nos collègues Gaëtan Gorce et
je vous rappelle et cela suffit à
maintenir cette expression que nous nous
situons ici dans la loi Informatique et
Liberté qui vise à protéger les
personnes à l'égard des traitements de
données à caractère personnel cette
expression
sera maintenue si vous ne l'acceptez le
gouvernement l'acceptant également je
ferai en outre observer
qu'à l'heure du numérique toute donnée
est aisément reproductible et qu'elle
peut être stockée à moindre coût en de
multiples endroits et en cas de fuite
les conséquences sont effectivement
irréversible pour illustrer mon propos
je prendrai l'exemple de l'accès à ce
que j'appellerai mon nuage
si j'avais recours demain une technique
biométrique pour accéder à mon espace
sur un Cloud et que celui-ci soit piraté
le hacker pourrait disposer de mon
identifiants et l'utiliser pour usurper
lui-même mon identité la conséquence est
tout de même grave car elle en serait
que je ne pourrai plus moi-même utiliser
cet élément biométrique pour
m'identifier à l'avenir autrement dit
une partie de moi-même ne
m'appartiendrait plus sous réserve
d'amendement attachée essentiellement à
affiner la rédaction de cette
proposition de loi et avec l'accord
unanime des membres de la commission des
lois je vous proposerai de l'adopter
merci mon cher collègue la parole était
madame Axel Lemaire secrétaire des
tâches chargé du numérique vous avez la
parole madame la ministre
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des lois
monsieur le sénateur Gorse monsieur le
rapporteur Pillet mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs voilà un débat qui nous
situe à l'interface entre le passé et
l'avenir
si c'est rond disait que si le visage et
le miroir de l'âme les yeux en sont les
interprètes
c'est dire que le corps a un sens et que
son utilisation n'est pas anodine
peut-être la raison pour laquelle le
peuple massaï en Tanzanie refuse d'être
photographié par crainte de voir son âme
volée
l'inquiétude qui perce dans le sujet que
nous examinons aujourd'hui est réel elle
correspond à un sentiment d'insécurité
présent chez les Français et qu'il faut
savoir entendre une étude récente du
credoch montrer que les Français sont
réservés sur l'usage de la biométrie
dans la vie quotidienne ils sont
d'accord pour que les données
biométriques soient utilisées lorsqu'il
s'agit des fichiers de police ou pour
les pièces d'identité
cela relève du domaine du régalien de
l'institutionnel de la sécurité
nationale
la réticence est plus forte en revanche
lorsque c'est donner sont amenées à être
utilisés dans un cadre marchant c'est
beaucoup moins accepté pour les
transactions bancaires par exemple moi
de 30 % des Français souhaite que leur
donner biométrique soit utilisée ce
conseil paradoxal si l'on considère
comme le montre les chiffres que les
Français sont très friands d'innovation
il s'agit là par ce texte que vous
proposez de lever le paradoxe entre ce
choix
d'une innovation du futur encore
inconnue et la préservation de certaines
libertés et du respect de la vie privée
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
considère avec le gouvernement que ce
débat est très utile et que vous avez
raison c'est ici qu'il doit avoir lieu
la législation française et complète
très protectrice des données
personnelles spécialement au regard
d'autres cadres législatifs en Europe ou
ailleurs dans le monde mais la loi de
1978 relative à l'informatique et aux
libertés ne précise pas la finalité qui
doit être poursuivie dans l'usage et le
recueil des données biométriques je
remercie donc ici les sénateurs et en
particulier monsieur le sénateur Gorce
et monsieur le sénateur pillé pour ce
travail qu'ils ont initié c'est un sujet
fondamental puisqu'il relève
effectivement de la question du corps
humain cela a été évoqué le chapitre 2
du Code civil relatif
à la dignité à l'intégrité du corps
humain sont là en filigrane de tout le
corpus réglementaire relatif aux données
biographies biométrique on voit bien que
l'esprit du Code civil doit nous
inspirer dans ce débat c'est d'autant
plus vrai que les données biométriques
ont des caractéristiques particulières
qui ont été déjà cités elles sont
irrévocables elles revêtent un caractère
d'unicité et de permanence
ce débat s'inscrit dans un contexte qui
est celui d'une réticence des Français
que j'ai déjà évoqué mais aussi d'un
usage croissant
aux applications biométriques et d'un
nombre croissant d'autorisation délivrée
par l'acné les usages se développent que
cela concerne les transactions de
paiement ou encore la reconnaissance
faciale ou vocale dans l'usage de
terminaux mobiles
alors faut-il faut-il d'emblée
s'insurger certaines applications
concrètes nous montrent que les données
biométriques peuvent avoir un usage
utile nous avons en France certaines
entreprises qui sont spécialistes et
leaders mondial de du développement des
terminaux biométrique qui combine par
exemple deux biométries pour limiter
justement les risques d'usurpation
d'identité la biométrie devient donc
utile pour répondre aux sentiments
d'insécurité née du progrès
technologique
d'autres exemples en particulier nés au
sein du pôle de compétitivité de Lille
montre qu'il est possible de développer
des prototypes de paiement avec une
authentification biométrique et un
stockage sécurisé qui sur un support qui
est détenu par les individus ici il
s'agit de payer pour une transaction
commerciale au moyen d'un support
autonome individuel qui contient des
données biométriques appartenant à un
individu mais détaché dans ce stockage
qui serait effectué par une entreprise
ou une tierce partie la France est aussi
à l'avant-garde de ce que l'on appelle
la crypto biométrie cela permet de
rendre les données biométriques
révocable en cas de vol de données il
est donc possible de rechercher et de
récupérer des données biométriques et
j'alerte ici sur le risque de bloquer la
recherche et le développement en
particulier dans ce secteur et puis cela
a été cité comme exemple le verrouillage
d'un téléphone portable grâce à l'usage
d'une empreinte digitale liée à un seul
doigt la réalité c'est que le niveau de
sécurité de ce que l'on peut considérer
être un gadget est assez faible et que
surtout il s'agit là d'un usage
domestique du téléphone et cela relève
de l'exception domestique telle qu'elle
est considérée par la CNIL puisque c'est
usage propre et laisser dans le
téléphone appartenant à l'individu et
n'est pas lié à une collecte extérieure
donc vous voyez les cas de figure sont
très divers d'où l'importance de
légiférer de manière éclairée et en lien
avec toutes ces applications pratiques
j'aurais pu aussi donner l'exemple des
élections au Mali quel rapport me
direz-vous et bien en l'absence d'état
civil dans un pays où l'état de guerre
n'a pas permis un recensement de la
population qui soit fiable bien c'est la
biométrie qui a permis de réaliser en
quelques mois ce recensement et
d'organiser un scrutin démocratique
grâce à la collecte d'empreintes
digitales
on peut considérer pour autant que les
risques liés à l'usage biométrique sont
aussi importants le risque d'usurpation
d'identité qui aurait des conséquences
graves de la perte ou de la corruption
des bases de données biométriques
prenons un exemple aux États-Unis
lorsque l'on arrive sur le sol américain
que ça soit par voie aérienne maritime
ou terrestre les empreintes digitales
qui sont prises au moment de l'arrivée
sont conservés pendant 75 ans je dois me
rendre à New York à la fin juin et bien
cela signifie que les Américains
détiendront mes empruntes digitales
jusqu'en 2089 est-ce là ce que l'on
souhaite pour notre pays et nos
concitoyens je pose la question en tout
cas cela aboutit à des pratiques des
pratiques extrêmes en particulier de
mutilation ou certaines personnes se
brûlent les doigts pour fausser les
pistes dans l'utilisation de leur donner
biométrique
et puis il est vrai que la
reconnaissance faciale notamment permise
sur certains réseaux sociaux ou en tout
cas qui fait l'objet de recherche à
l'heure actuelle peut induire un
sentiment de dépossession on sait que
une fonction qui est autorisée aux
États-Unis de recherche de l'identité
par l'image ne l'est pas en Europe grâce
à une législation protectrice mais pour
combien de temps et puis en fin
concernant tout particulièrement les
mineurs il y a un risque sans doute réel
d'une banalisation de l'usage des
données biométriques avec une
accoutumance à cet usage et donc une
acceptation du confort commercial que
peut induire ses usages donc toutes ces
questions doivent être posées d'où
l'importance de ce débat pour autant et
j'en viens au texte
plus précisément je regrette le fait
qu'il ne soit pas accompagné d'une étude
particulièrement vrai de l'étude
d'impact économique nous avons en France
des sociétés innovantes qui ont
développé des technologies en lien avec
le secteur de la confiance numérique
c'est un secteur en plein essor qui
justement fait de la France et de sa
législation protectrice en matière de
données une une source d'attractivité
économique nos sociétés ont dû s'adapter
au cadre législatif et réglementaire et
développer des technologies qui sont
aujourd'hui recherchés à l'étranger il
eût fallu pouvoir analyser l'impact
d'une nouvelle législation sur ce
domaine économique et industriel qui
embauchent des dizaines de milliers de
salariés en France nous touchons là à
l'économie de la donnée de la data or il
est désormais
de dire qu'il s'agit du pétrole du 21e
siècle les services aujourd'hui sont
tournés et seront à l'avenir plus encore
tourné vers la collecte de la donnée il
faut à la fois s'inscrire dans la
tradition des valeurs fondamentales
françaises mais aussi ne pas bloquer
l'innovation en ce domaine
le rapporteur a fait certaines
propositions avec lesquelles je suis en
plein accord par exemple permettre grâce
à la biométrie l'accès à des locaux ou
un ordinateur à des fins de sécurité
cela va d'ailleurs dans le sens de la
jurisprudence de la CNIL qui lors de la
vie salariale au sein d'une entreprise
autorise l'usage de la donnée
biométrique pour l'accès aux locaux et
pour l'accès à la cantine ce n'est pas
vrai du contrôle des horaires qui n'est
désormais plus autorisé pour par le
recours à la donnée biométrique le
rapporteur
veut aussi permettre l'authentification
par un paiement je crois que c'est là un
domaine qui est une technologie d'avenir
et qu'il ne faut pas fermer les
possibilités technologiques à cet égard
en revanche il est proposé interdire
l'usage de la biométrie au mineur en
particulier dans les cantines scolaires
cela me sens me paraît relever du bon
sens il est également proposé
d'interdire a priori l'usage pour
accéder à des services tels les piscines
là aussi le débat reste ouvert mais on
peut s'interroger sur l'utilité de la
donnée biométrique pour ces technologies
pour ces usages dit de confort
le la proposition de loi aurait
bénéficié de d'être accompagné d'une
analyse des risques une analyse des
risques qu'est-ce que c'est derrière une
terminologie un peu technique du point
de vue de la sécurité des systèmes
d'information cela vise à objectiver les
mesures de sécurité à réaliser pour
répondre à des risques qui sont
identifiés en fonction de certains
critères par exemple le nombre de
personnes concernées le type de données
collectées l'infrastructure informatique
utilisée or en l'espèce aucune analyse
de risque n'est conduite en fonction des
cas particuliers qui peuvent se
présenter il n'y a pas non plus
d'évaluations d'impact sur la vie privée
or ces évaluations d'impact qui sont
relativement récentes pour dans le droit
des données se répandent et sont très
certainement utiles aux législateur
comme aux citoyens et aux entreprises
lorsqu'il s'agit de légiférer en matière
de données personnelles on pourrait donc
considérer qu'une telle évaluation
serait
utile enfin un travail en collaboration
avec des institutions tel la CNIL ou
Lancy qui a développé certaines
méthodes de travail pour
développer des processus de certificat
des normes de confiance sur d'autres
secteurs que celui de la confiance
numérique est bien une consultation par
exemple de l'ancy ou
les l'exploration de pistes de travail
avec ces institutions pour être
utile
alors la position du gouvernement elle
consiste d'abord à saluer le travail des
parlementaires et à s'assurer du soutien
dans la poursuite de l'objectif qui a
été exprimée il faut fixer effectivement
par la voie législative des principes
clairs qui doivent à la fois guider les
autorités administratives indépendantes
dans leur travail et en mais sans
freiner l'innovation
biométrique par exemple dans le cas des
expérimentations il faut permettre que
la recherche et le développement se
poursuivent en la matière
alors le gouvernement propose un
amendement pour améliorer le texte tout
en maintenant à notre sens l'équilibre
qui a été trouvé par la commission des
lois avec deux objectifs précis liés à
cette amendement d'abord clarifier la
finalité pour laquelle les traitements
pourraient être autorisés dans le texte
de la commission de finalités sont cités
d'abord celle du contrôle d'accès et
puis celle de la protection des
personnes des biens et des données il me
semble que c'est cette dernière finalité
qui est la plus pertinente et puis un
second objectif poursuivi par
l'amendement du déposé par le
Gouvernement celui de clarifier la
notion d'enjeux dépassant l'intérêt de
l'organisme
cette notion nous semble insuffisamment
précise
elle elle utilise un langage qui est
celui de la CNIL mais enfin en tout cas
se rapproche de la doctrine technique de
la CNIL mais relève moins du domaine de
la loi il me semble que nous devrions
affiner la terminologie juridique en ce
domaine notamment pour continuer à
permettre le paiement
lors d'un paiement l'intérêt de la
sécurité ne se limite pas à l'intérêt du
marchand il s'étend à l'intérêt de
l'usager du consommateur mais aussi du
marché économique de manière générale
puisque la sécurité de la transaction
participe de la confiance des acteurs
économiques dans leur ensemble pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons je propose de
continuer ce travail qui a été initié
par les sénateurs notamment peut-être si
vous en êtes d'accord par la création
d'un groupe de travail
qui permettrait de d'affiner les
réflexions sur ce sujet entre la lecture
de la proposition de loi au Sénat et son
examen à l'Assemblée nationale en
fonction du calendrier législatif et du
calendrier du travail gouvernemental il
sera peut-être possible d'intégrer
certaines des dispositions adoptées ou à
tout le monde examiner par les
parlementaires dans le futur projet de
loi il y a une tradition française de
protection des données il s'agit vous
l'aurez compris de ne pas aller à
l'encontre de cette tradition au
contraire de l'affirmer et d'en faire
une source d'attractivité au plan
international pour autant dans ce débat
entre liberté d'une part et sécurité de
l'autre il s'agit aussi de trouver la
frontière juste qui permettra de ne pas
freiner l'innovation en France mais au
contraire d'encourager les acteurs
économiques et la puissance publique à
agir en bonne conscience merci
Madame le Ministre dans la suite de
discussion générale la parole est à
Madame Virginie Claisse pour 10 minutes
vous avez la parole ma chère collègue
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues beaucoup de choses
ont déjà été dites sur le sujet
il est vrai que ce qui est peut-être le
plus surprenant dans les constats qu'on
fait aujourd'hui c'est la perception
qu'on les Français des données
biométriques la perception et la
connaissance
qu'ils en ont l'étude du Crédoc a déjà
été rappelé et les Français sont assez
d'accord
pour craindre un détournement des
données biométriques par les entreprises
privées ou les employeurs sont d'accord
par contre
pour les faire confiance à l'institution
notamment en matière de sécurité pour ce
qui est de l'usage des données
biométriques
et parallèlement ont une certaine
inconscience je pense vous
méconnaissance de toutes les traces
biométriques qu'on laisse partout où
l'on passe
de façon automatique en vous écoutant
madame la ministre tout à l'heure je
pensais aussi à ces phéromones par
exemple dont personne n'a encore parlé
qui sont ces substances chimiques un peu
particulières mais qu'ici chaque
individu qui signe chacun d'entre nous
et qui font partie de ces données
biométriques qui feront sans doute
l'objet d'investigation de la part des
entreprises qui s'intéressent aux
données biométriques et qui sont cette
fois-ci parfaitement inconscientes et je
crois totalement méconnue et inconnu de
des Français donc il y a cet espace à la
fois d'acceptation et de rejets de
crainte de ce que l'on va faire des
données biométriques et puis pour autant
une certaine inconscience à aller
laisser sans vraiment sans apercevoir et
on assiste de ce fait à une banalisation
me semble-t-il dangereuse de ce qu'on
appelle la biométrie de service on l'a
vu on en a parlé monsieur rapporteur
vous l'avez particulièrement signalé
dans dans votre rapport tous ces
dispositifs autour de la restauration
qui utilise la reconnaissance
biométrique autour même des loisirs dans
certains cas
il y a même un département où il y a une
gestion de carte de fidélité qui utilise
des données biométriques donc tous ces
usages
banalisés des données biométriques
doivent me semble-t-il faire l'objet de
l'attention particulière du législateur
et doit faire l'objet aussi de pédagogie
et d'explications auprès des Français
vous l'avez dit monsieur le rapporteur
très bien tout à l'heure finalement
c'est donner biométriques c'est une
partie de moi et c'est une partie de moi
qui m'échappe sans que je l'ai voulu
sans que je l'ai accepté sans que j'en
ai été conscient un moment ou un autre
je crois que c'est pour ça qu'il est
important de bien expliquer de bien dire
et profitons-en aujourd'hui puisque le
sujet est abordé et publiquement
bien dire que la force
la puissance de cet outil des données
biométriques est aujourd'hui liée au
développement des logiciels au
développement de l'informatique tout
notre corps tout ce que nous pensons pas
pensons mais tout ce qui est émane de
notre corps peut aujourd'hui être
numérisé ensuite logique et conserver de
façon très simple et très signante de
nous dans les dans les logiciels
informatiques et par croisement de
fichiers ou par croisement informatique
être retrouvé on parle souvent de
génétique et de chromosomes donc on a
tous en tête l'image du petit chromosome
en X etc etc ou en y on oublie qu'en
fait la signature chromosomique c'est
pas ça c'est une succession ce qu'on
appelle de base azotées qu'on a
l'habitude dans les milieux bio de
désignés par leur initial donc à TGC et
donc c'est cette succession
atgcat etc qui nous signe de façon très
unique
dans les logiciels informatiques qui
permettent de nous retrouver de façon
unique quand on parle de données
biométriques je suis pas certaine que
les Français pensent à leur comportement
pense à leur démarche pense à la façon
qu'ils ont de taper sur l'ordinateur et
sur le clavier de l'ordinateur tout ça
ce sont des données biométriques qui
sont importantes une fois de plus qui
sont très signantes de chacun d'entre
nous et ce qui autrefois faisait la
frontière pour l'acnil entre traçons et
non traçant disparaît aujourd'hui il a
encore monsieur le rapporteur vous
l'avez souligné dans votre rapport par
exemple tout ce qui est reconnaissances
faciale est aujourd'hui traçant dans la
mesure où la vidéo protection s'est
développée et vous de nombreuses images
de nous sont enregistrés et permettent
de nous retrouver et de nous de nous
identifier grâce à ces phénomènes de
reconnaissance faciale grâce à tout ce
qui est développé autour de la
reconnaissance faciale donc je partage
bien évidemment toutes les réserves
énoncées si bien énoncées d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure par notre collègue Gaëtan
Gaëtan Gorce sur les données
biométriques et sur leur
utilisation et sur la nécessité de les
protéger et de les considérer comme
effectivement une partie de nous une
partie du corps humain un violable en
principe en tout cas devrait l'être même
si aujourd'hui le texte de loi qui nous
est proposé ne va pas jusque là ne va
pas jusqu'à donner un statut aux données
biométriques alors vous l'avez dit
madame la ministre notamment et d'autres
avant vous leur apporteur et Gaetan
gosse l'ont dit c'est vrai que
et heureusement les données biométriques
et l'utilisation des biométriques ont
des avantages notamment limités
l'usurpation d'identité mais on va
revenir au débat que nous avons eu dans
cet instant dans cette haute assemblée
au moment de la carte nationale
d'identité électronique ce qui fait
débat ce qui faisait débats beaucoup
plus c'était pas tellement la donnée
biométrique en elle mais en elle-même
c'était son stockage et là il est
important je pense de bien expliquer
aussi la différence entre un stockage
centralisé qui ne pourra jamais être
sécurisé à 100% qui sera toujours
disponible malheureusement pour des
hackers ou pour des gens
particulièrement mal intentionnés et un
stockage limité
à l'endroit à l'accès que l'on veut
protéger un stockage limité à une carte
ou un badge porté par l'individu avec
ses empreintes électrique à lui c'est
donner biométriques à lui donc il
maîtrise il faut bien expliquer aussi la
différence entre l'authentification de
quelqu'un et son identification donc
l'authentification qui ne peut se faire
qu'en présence de la personne et donc du
corps et du prolongement du corps
qu'elle a donné biométrique à un moment
précis et un endroit précis donc toutes
ces choses sont me semble-t-il
extrêmement importantes à prendre en
considération et à ne surtout pas
oublier d'expliquer quand on parle aux
Français des données biométriques la
biométrie c'est pas seulement
l'empreinte digitale c'est pas seulement
l'ADN c'est le comportement c'est tout
ce que l'on émette tout ce qui vient de
notre corps tout ce qui vient de nous
tout ce qui nous signe et que on peut
aujourd'hui mettre en équation
mathématique ou mettre en succession en
mathématiques et qui grâce
à l'informatique grâce au développement
formidable des logiciels et de
l'informatique permet de nous retrouver
et de nous retracer dans de multiples
endroits donc bien évidemment nous
suivrons gaët angorse sur le sur le
sujet et nous voterons cette proposition
de loi tout en étant conscient que elle
ne règle pas tout en étant conscient que
elle doit s'inscrire effectivement dans
un débat sur les Numériques tout en
étant conscient que il ne faut pas c'est
vrai empêcher pour autant le
développement technologique mais que ce
développement technologique cette
recherche doivent se faire dans un cadre
imposé par le législateur qui est un
cadre respectueux d'un équilibre
nécessaire entre les libertés publiques
et privées et effectivement la recherche
et la technologie et la position de la
France sur la scène mondiale sur le
sujet donc il nous semble que ce texte
va dans ce sens il reste effectivement
du travail à faire il reste le texte
examinés notamment la loi la loi sur les
numériques qui va qui va venir en
discussion d'ici peu mais c'est déjà un
premier pas important que de limiter
l'usage des données biométriques à ceux
qui relève de la stricte nécessité de
sécurité même si ces termes ont
effectivement été explicités par des
amendements notamment de notre
rapporteur et je crois expliciter encore
par un amendement du Gouvernement qu'on
examinait en commission ce matin donc
nous voterons ce texte sans aucune
hésitation proposée par Gaëtan gorff en
le remercions de son travail et en
remercions aussi le rapporteur pour le
travail qu'il a fait sur la rédaction du
sujet merci mes chers collègues dans la
Sud discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur François Fortassin pour 6
minutes
monsieur le président
madame la ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
sur le rapporteur sur l'auteur
de cette proposition de loi mes chers
collègues
l'air de la biottechnologie et de
l'informatique permet désormais l'entrée
des phénomènes propres à la vie de
l'espèce humaine dans l'ordre du savoir
et du pouvoir et par conséquent dans le
domaine du droit
cette nouvelle ère conduit à une mise en
réseau croissante de donner
individuelles parmi lesquels certains
sont identifiantes notamment les données
biométriques à l'heure de l'essor de la
biométrie dans de nombreux domaines de
la vie courante ces techniques posent
des questions critiques en matière de
sécurité et de liberté question
auxquelles législateur se doivent
répondre la biométrie est un dispositif
qui permet d'identifier l'individu à
partir de caractéristiques physiques
biologique voir comportementale elles
sont produites par le corps lui-même et
le désigne façon définitive permettant
de ce fait le traçage des individus et
leur identification certaine
la liste des procédés biométriques
actuellement opérationnels va de l'ADN à
l'empreinte digitale à l'empreinte
palmaire en passant par la rétine l'iris
la reconnaissance faciale la géométrie
contour de la main la voix
l'écriture manuscrite qui se traduit par
une analyse dynamique des gestes usuels
accomplie pour chacun pour signer ou
encore la façon de taper sur un clavier
or aujourd'hui le risque est bien celui
de la banalisation du recours à la
biométrie et la tentation de la
substituer à d'autres outils de
sécurisation tout aussi performants en
toute circonstance pour exemple cette
diversification des usages de la
biométrie le 18 juin 2009 lactine a
autorisé pour la première fois le
recours un système biométrique
reposant sur la reconnaissance du réseau
veineux pour lutter contre la fraude à
un examen mais il faut pas laisser
croire qu'il n'y a que cette phrase qui
pourrait être décelée dans ce domaine
l'imagination est très fertile il y aura
toujours des preuves qui ne sont pas qui
ne seront pas décelés
l'identification biométrique est devenue
une partie courante dans les entreprises
pour le contrôle et l'accès au locaux
notamment mais encore le contrôle de
l'accès physique aux cantine scolaires
au cours de loisirs aux salles de sport
au cercle de jeu etc
lorsque ça s'arrête là c'est excellent
il peut y avoir des débordements dans ce
domaine
la signature document électronique la
gestion d'une carte de fidélité l'accès
à un dossier médical partagé à ce propos
je pense que la biométrie peut être très
utilisée notamment pour les tons
d'organes
et là il y a une un champ à explorer qui
n'a pas été encore totalement investiés
cette diversification des usages de la
biométrie qui se double d'une
banalisation est en grande partie due au
contrôle souple effectué par l'acnil la
loi Informatique et Liberté 2014 qui a
modifié celle de janvier qui 78 a
subordonné tous les traitements
automatisés comportant des données
biométriques nécessaires au contrôle de
l'identité des personnes à
l'autorisation peut être préalable acné
sauf ceux qui sont mis en oeuvre pour le
compte de l'État pour lequel
seul son avis est requis
toutefois afin de faciliter la tâche de
cette autorité des dispositifs
biométriques qui visent une même
finalité des catégories de données et de
destinataires identiques sont autorisés
par des décisions en cadres de la CNIL
appelé autorisation unique les risques
d'une généros généralisation de ce
biopouvoir sont en effet grand je veux
prendre pour exemple l'usage récent de
cette technique par un fabricant de
téléphone comme
la signaler madame la ministre
que fabricant de téléphone qui a intégré
un capteur biométrique permettra aux
smartphones de se déverrouiller au
passage du doigt de son utilisateur et
qui a récemment été piraté l'initiative
de notre collègue Gorce est à ce propos
extrêmement heureux
elle nous met face à nos responsabilités
quelle est l'avenir du traitement des
données notamment de ces données
individualisantes permettant la
traçabilité
la surveillance effectuée par la NASA
qui aide également capté les secrets ou
la simple vie privée des Français dans
une ampleur pour l'instant inégalé sur
la période de 30 jours de décembre 2012
à janvier 2013 plus de 60 millions
d'enregistrements de données
téléphoniques des Français ont été des
Français ont été effectués par la NASA
et ceux à ce titre on voit que les
débordements peuvent être aussi
édifiants reste cependant à pouvoir
traiter toutes ces données qui demandent
quand même beaucoup de temps la
proposition de notre collègue qui est en
Corse à le mérite susciter le
questionnement elle conditionne
l'autorisation de la mise en oeuvre d'un
traitement biométrique à une stricte
nécessité de sécurité définie comme la
sécurité des personnes et des biens ou
la protection des informations dont la
divulgation le détournement ou la
destruction porterait un préjudice grave
et réversible consciente des difficultés
modifier les temps antérieures de la
législation elle prend également soin de
prévoir un dispositif transitoire de ce
nouveau régime d'autorisation toutefois
j'en viendrai maintenant à quelques
réserves que le groupe RDSE qui a malgré
tout à exprimer le texte proposé laisse
de côté la construction d'une définition
de données biométrique par ailleurs les
moyens mis à disposition de la CNIL sont
insuffisants comme la faire remarquer
notre collègue François pillier il
semble que la question du calendrier de
cette proposition de loi est jouée étant
donné que dans l'état actuel des
discussions sur le règlement européen
relative au traitement des données
personnelles ce texte ne pouvait être
que d'ambition modestes et l'on peut
dire qu'il nous arrive de manière trop
précoce l'ensemble des bas futurs dans
un délai de deux années en fonction de
l'avancée négociation à l'échelle
européenne un certain nombre
d'ajustements de la législation
française notamment la loi du 6 janvier
78 ce ne seront nécessaires au fin
d'harmonisation le règlement
pourrait aussi substituer à la
contrainte a priori un renforcement a
posteriorer de la responsabilité des
opérateurs par ailleurs le gouvernement
doit prochainement présenter un projet
de loi sur les libertés numériques qui
permettra en débat global sur ces
questions relatives aux enjeux nationaux
et internationaux qui évitera ainsi une
approche trop-staciée sous ses réserves
notamment calendaires mon groupe
approuvera pour la proposition de loi
dans notre collègue va être en Corse
j'ai un collègue dans la suite
discussion générale la parole est à
Madame Esther Benbassa pour 6 minutes
vous avez la parole ma chère collègues
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues elle est donnée biométriques
ne sont pas des données comme les autres
puisqu'elles ont la particularité des
spécifiques à un individu et permanent
ainsi permettait le traçage des
personnes et leur identification
certaine
le caractère sensible et très personnel
de ces données nécessitent un
encadrement un contrôle de leur collecte
j'ajouterai cependant
tandis qu'aujourd'hui sur internet par
exemple la frontière entre privée et
publique tant à s'estomper le danger de
violation éventuelle de l'espace de
l'espace privé ne se limite évidemment
pas à la seule utilisation des données
biométriques nous attendons donc avec un
pense impatience que le projet de loi
sur les libertés numériques promis par
le gouvernement soit présenté et soumis
au Parlement de plus de plus en plus de
dispositifs de reconnaissance
biométrique sont mis en place et
notamment pour contrôler l'accès à des
locaux professionnels commerciaux
scolaires ou de loisirs comme ont de
nombreux domaines tout est ici à faire
de mesures un usage abusif de ces
techniques biométriques éviter puisque
les données biométriques ne sont pas des
données comme les autres elles sont
intrinsèques à l'individu et le
définissent irrémédiablement en même
temps il convient de ne pas ouvrir la
voie un verrouillage
risquons d'arrêter les innovations en
matière de technique biométrique surtout
qu'il s'agit d'un domaine de pointe en
France et pourvoyeur d'emploi d'ailleurs
j'ajouterai qu'il s'agit
ce serait plutôt une chimère de croire
qu'on peut verrouiller et en la matière
en revanche mettre en place un système
biométrique pour que de jeunes enfants
puissent aller à la cantine ou à la
piscine est-ce bien raisonnable
au groupe écologiste nous sommes loin
d'un être convaincu et souscrivons aux
propos de notre collègue à lecture qui
déclarait en 2011 face au développement
inexorable de la biométrie et à
l'ouverture du monde sur les
nanotechnologies la sensibilisation des
individus et des juristes à cette
question et la volonté d'agir maintenant
apparaissent absolument nécessaire dans
20 ans il sera trop tard
au regard du droit et des libertés
fondamentaux
biométrie oppose à l'évidence le Droit
Individuel à la protection des données
et au respect de la vie privée à
l'exigence collective de sûreté elle
invite donc à trouver un équilibre entre
ses droits intérêts légitimes certes la
mise en place de dispositifs biométrique
est soumises à l'autorisation préalable
de la CNIL toutefois la collecte et le
traitement des données ne sont
conditionnées à aucune finalité
particulière c'est cette lacune que la
présente proposition de loi se propose
de combler et nous partageons la volonté
des auteurs de mettre en place des
garde-fous en la matière il s'agit ainsi
de compléter la loi du 6 janvier 1978
Informatique et Liberté afin de
conditionner l'usage des données
biométriques à une nécessité stricte de
sécurité et rien d'autre et de répondre
un souci de proportionnalité dans la
démarche entre la nature de
l'information ou du site à sécuriser et
la technologie utilise la sécurité étant
entendue comme celle des personnes et
des biens ou comme la protection des
informations dont la divulgation le
détournement ou la destruction
porteraient un préjudice grave et
irréversible nous nous situons ici dans
la droite ligne du Conseil de l'Europe
qui a l'occasion de la révision de la
Convention pour la protection des
personnes à l'égard du traitement
automatisé des données à caractère
personnel dites convention 108 invitez
le législateur français à se pencher sur
cette question
l'article 6 du projet final de
convention
stipule en effet que le traitement de
données biométrique
identifiant un individu de façon unique
n'est autorisée qu'à la condition que la
loi applicable prévoit des garanties
appropriées venant compléter celle de la
présente convention et de préciser que
les garanties appropriées doivent être
de nature à prévenir les risques que le
traitement de données sensibles peut
présenter pour les intérêts droits et
libertés fondamentales de la personne
concernée notamment un risque de
discrimination
le groupe écologiste est très attachée à
la défense de la protection de la vie
privée et du corps humain ainsi que plus
généralement
de la défense des libertés individuelles
nous soutiendrons ce texte à condition
que l'évolution des techniques
biométriques sécurisées ne soient pas
non plus en travers par une telle PPL
merci
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Yves de traîne pour 8 minutes
le ciel président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues le texte que nous
examinons aujourd'hui témoigne une
nouvelle fois du souci du Sénat de se
dresser en protecteur et défenseur des
libertés individuelles il est important
de le souligner alors que trop souvent
notre Haute Assemblée la cible de
critique c'est le Sénat qui a joué un
rôle pionnier dans les années 70 lors de
la formation des premières autorités
administratives indépendantes c'est
notre chambre également qui a été en
avance sur les débats et les sujets dit
moderne j'en prendrai pour simple
exemple la proposition de loi visant à
mieux garantir le droit à la vie privée
à l'heure du numérique adopté par notre
assemblée le 23 mars 2010 à la suite du
rapport d'information réalisée par
Anne-Marie Escoffier moi-même jamais
inscrite hélas à l'ordre du jour de
l'Assemblée nationale la biométrie cette
science qui regroupe l'ensemble des
techniques informatiques visant à
reconnaître automatiquement un individu
à partir de ces caract statistiques
physiques biologique voire
comportementale évolue toujours plus la
première génération des techniques liées
à la reconnaissance anatomique à savoir
les empreintes digitales ou oculaires
laissent progressivement place à des
procédés de reconnaissance dynamique
tels que l'analyse de la démarche ou
même de la frappe au clavier
d'ordinateur tous ces progrès sont il
est vrai impressionnant sur le plan
technique or il semblerait que nous
assistons aujourd'hui à une banalisation
excessive de l'usage de la biométrie qui
touche pourtant à ce qu'il y a de plus
personnel et de plus intime pour tous
les individus
vos empreintes votre ADN votre iris bref
tout ce qui vous distingue en dernier
lieu de tout autre personne sur la terre
la biométrie s'insinue ainsi dans tous
les aspects de notre vie quotidienne le
succès peut être trop éclatant de ces
technologies fait peser un risque
important sur les libertés de nos
concitoyens on imagine peut-être encore
difficilement ce à quoi pourrait aboutir
un détournement massif de ces données
mais il est clair que celles-ci sont
trop précieuses et trop sensibles pour
être banalisé et que les techniques
permettant leur recueil et leur
traitement sont trop intrusives pour
être aussi largement diffusé
il est donc important qu'intervienne le
législateur en 2011 notre collègue Alex
turc ancien président de la CNIL a
indiqué déjà je cite que face au
développement inexorable de la biométrie
et à l'ouverture du monde sur les
nanotechnologies la sensibilisation des
individus et des juristes à cette
question et la volonté d'agir maintenant
apparaissent absolument nécessaire et il
ajoutait dans 20 ans il sera trop tard
en effet ainsi que le souligne fort
justement notre collègue Gaëtan Gorce
dans sa proposition de loi le régime
juridique actuel de la régulation des
techniques biométriques ne semblent plus
adaptées aux usages contemporains de ces
technologies la loi du 6 août 2004
relative aux données biométriques
avaient pourtant doté la France d'un
régime particulièrement protecteur et
unique en Europe avec la mise en place
d'un contrôle a priori par la voie de la
délivrance d'une autorisation préalable
regardé par une autorité administrative
indépendante la CNIL presque 10 ans plus
tard au vu des évolutions technologiques
les législateurs que nous sommes peuvent
penser que ce régime laisse peut-être
une part trop importante de la décision
à la CNIL qui demeure finalement la
seule compétence pour autoriser l'emploi
de ces techniques or cette autorité
administrative si elle est indépendante
n'est pas pour autant toute puissante
elle ne dispose pas de pouvoir de
contrôle suffisant pour parer à toutes
les éventualités des risques liés à une
banalisation ou une diffusion trop
grande de ces techniques et des données
collectives en outre la loi en vigueur
ne conditionne pas l'octroi de
l'autorisation préalable à des finalités
particulières ou à des modalités
spécifiques de contrôle la CNIL a donc
dû développer sa propre doctrine
d'intervention pour faire face à la
demande massive et exponentielle
d'utilisation de techniques biométriques
nous partageons tous dans cette
hémicycle le sentiment que ce système
n'est plus satisfaisant en l'état
en effet les données biométriques si
elles ne sauraient se confondre avec le
corps humain lui-même sont la production
et le prolongement de ce dernier elles
peuvent donc être utilisées à des fins a
priori sensible dès lors l'intervention
du législateur est justifiée par
l'article 34 de la Constitution lui-même
qui nous dit que la loi fixe les règles
concernant les droits civiques et les
garanties fondamentales accordées aux
citoyens pour l'exercice des libertés
publiques
deux voix nous aider théoriquement
ouverte soit un accroissement des
pouvoirs de la CNIL soit une définition
en amont resserré et restrictive du
domaine du biométrique et de ses
applications
c'est la deuxième option qui a été
retenue par notre collègue Gaëtan Gorce
auteur de la présente proposition de loi
à titre personnel je pense que c'est le
choix le plus avisé et le plus approprié
au regard des enjeux qui sont devant
nous en effet
afin d'éviter une banalisation excessive
il paraît opportun de limiter ce
phénomène en amont plutôt que de
chercher à contrôler les conséquences
qui pour leur nous dépassent si la
rédaction initiale de leur proposition
de loi avait le mérite de poser le
problème elle ne parvenait pas à le
résoudre en se contentant de
conditionner l'octroi de l'autorisation
de la CNIL à je cite de strict nécessité
de sécurité et aurait contraint
l'administration à formuler un certain
nombre de mesures réglementaires au sein
de précision or celle-ci n'a pas à
donner d'injonctions à une autorité
indépendante aussi je tiens à saluer le
travail effectué par notre commission
des lois sous l'égide de son rapporteur
multiplier en dressant une liste plus
spécifique d'usage de la biométrie le
texte tel qu'il est issu de la
commission tant à établir un statut
voire une définition de la donnée
biométrique dans tous les cas ce
dispositif désormais proposé permet au
moins de justifier en droit et au niveau
législatif l'autorisation de l'emploi
des techniques biométriques il prévoit
en outre les mesures transitoires
nécessaires à assurer une pleine entière
sécurité juridique quant à la mise en
oeuvre du texte au-delà de ce satisfait
site adresser à notre rapporteur et à
notre commission je tiens à saluer
l'initiative de notre collègue Gorce
j'espère désormais que le débat
prospérera et que nous parviendrons à
transcrire dans la loi l'équilibre
manifestement opportun qui a été dégagé
par la rédaction de cette ex c'est
pourquoi le groupe
U di UC votera en faveur du présentex
dans la rédaction retenue par la
commission des lois je vous remercie
merci mon chers collègues dans la suite
discussion générale la parole est à
Madame Éliane assassie pour 7 minutes
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues comme le souligne le
rapport de notre collègue François
Pillet je cite la biométrie est
usuellement définie comme en passant
l'ensemble des procédés tendant à
identifier un individu à partir de la
mesure de lune ou de plusieurs de ses
caractéristiques physiques
psychologiques physiologique pardon ou
comportemental au vu de cette définition
si l'on conçoit que les technologies et
usages biométriques peuvent avoir de
bonnes utilités et ne sont pas mauvais
en soi on devine aussi aisément la
gravité des dérives dont ils peuvent
faire l'objet ainsi nous avons
semble-t-il la responsabilité de
légiférer afin de les encadrer et
trouver le juste équilibre qui
préservera les droits individuels le
régime d'autorisation préalable de
traitement de données biométriques dont
c'est doté la France et est déjà en soi
un régime protecteur cependant je
partage le constat de mes collègues la
loi de 2004 qui confie donc à la CNIL la
d'autoriser les traitements de données
biométriques ne prévoit rien sur la
pertinence des différents usages des
techniques biométriques c'est donc cette
lacune législative que la présente
proposition de loi de notre collègue
Gaëtan Gorce à pour objet de combler en
précisant les conditions de finalité
dans lesquelles peuvent être autorisées
les traitements automatisés comportant
des données biométriques nécessaires au
contrôle de l'identité des personnes
alors l'exposé des motifs de la
proposition de loi cite à titre
d'exemple et dérives constatées dans les
cantines scolaires cela déjà été dit
usant et abusant de cette technologie je
citerai aussi pour ma part le danger
d'une telle banalisation dans le milieu
de l'entreprise ou la biométrie devient
un moyen supplémentaire de suivre à la
trace à la minute les salariés nous
saluons donc la démarche de nos
collègues porteuses de protection
supplémentaire pour les libertés
individuelles
cependant la proposition de loi ne
concerne qu'une certaine catégorie de
traitement des données biométriques elle
exclut le traitement des données
biométriques dont la mise en oeuvre est
faite pour le compte de l'État alors je
comprends bien le choix de nos collègues
dans un temps qui est relativement
contraint de limiter le champ de leur
propositions néanmoins je voudrais
utiliser le temps qu'il m'est imparti
pour attirer votre attention sur un
autre danger de notre législation
relative au traitement des données
biométriques en effet la question du
respect des libertés publiques se trouve
souvent posées dans le traitement des
données mises en oeuvre pour le compte
de l'État je l'ai dit je pense notamment
ici au fichier automatisé des empreintes
digitales ou encore le fichier national
automatisé des empreintes génétiques
alors que les récentes remises en cause
de notre législation par la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme sur le
fichier automatisé des empreintes
digitales invitent
le gouvernement a modifié le décret du 8
avril 87 qui a institué ce fichier ce
qui je crois est en cours le Parlement
doit aussi s'emparer de cette question
afin de réformer le cadre général du
fichage dans un arrêt du 18 avril 2013 a
fait MK contre France la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme a jugé que la
France avait commis une violation de
l'article 8 de la Convention européenne
de sauvegarde des droits de l'homme et
des libertés fondamentales au terme
duquel toute personne a droit au respect
de la vie privée à propos du fichier
donc automatisé des empreintes digitales
alors selon la Cour la France a je la
cite outrepasser sa marge d'appréciation
en la matière tant en ce qui concerne
l'arbitraire du fichage que la durée de
conservation des données elle a estimé
je cite encore que le régime de
conservation dans le fichier litigieux
des empreintes digitales de personnes
soupçonnées d'avoir commis des
infractions mais non condamnées
il a été appliqué au requérant l'espèce
ne traduit pas un juste équilibre entre
les intérêts publics et privés
concurrents en jeu dès lors je continue
la citation la conservation litigieuse
analyse en une atteinte disproportionnée
au droit du requérant au respect de sa
vie privée et ne peut pas passer pour
nécessaire dans une société démocratique
fin de citation la cour appelle aussi et
ceux de manière plus générale que le
droit interne doit notamment assurer que
ces données soient pertinentes et non
excessives par rapport aux finalités
pour lesquelles elles sont enregistrées
qu'elles soient conservées sous une
forme permettant l'identification des
personnes concernées pendant une durée
nexcédant pas celle nécessaire aux
finalité pour lesquelles elles sont
enregistrées il doit aussi contenir les
garanties de nature à protéger
efficacement les données à caractère
personnel enregistré là encore fin de
citation mes chers collègues s'est
arrêté qui remet en cause un décret que
seul le gouvernement peut modifier à une
portée qui dépasse le fichier automatisé
des empreintes digitales pour
s'appliquer à notre code de procédure
pénale qui régit un fichier similaire le
Fnac à ce fichier devrait s'appliquer
les mêmes principes de proportionnalité
de pertinence de non excessivité et non
stigmatisation or vous le savez le chant
des infractions concernées par le fnae
initialement limité aux infractions à
caractère sexuel a été considérablement
étendu par Nicolas Sarkozy à la plupart
des infractions même mineur prévu au
code pénal notre ex président c'est
toutefois bien gardé de l'élargir au
demi financiers tels que le délit
d'initié la fraude fiscale ou la butte
de bien social
n'est-ce pas monsieur le Président yes
vous n'ignorez pas notre combat visant à
empêcher que des militants syndicaux des
salariés en lutte pour faire valoir
leurs droits sociaux ou encore de
simples manifestants trouvent leur
donner biométriques enregistrées pour
une durée indéterminée aux côtés des
auteurs de crimes de viol de trafic de
drogue ou des membres du Grand
banditierisme en complément de notre
proposition de loi portant amnistie des
faits commis à l'occasion d'activités
syndicales et revendicative nous avons
récemment déposé une autre proposition
de loi visant à encadrer le fichage
génétique et à interdire le fichage des
personnes poursuivies pour des faits
commis à l'occasion d'activités
syndicales et revendicative tout comme
les préoccupations exprimées par la
proposition de loi qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui notre proposition de loi se
veut aussi être le reflet interne des
exigences qui se font jour au niveau
international mais elle se veut surtout
être le reflet d'une société qui refuse
que notre code de procédure pénale
traite ces militants syndicaux comme des
criminels en puissance ainsi si nous
votons pour cette proposition de loi je
suis persuadé que nous aurons très vite
à nous pencher de manière plus poussée
non simplement sur l'usage mais aussi
sur le traitement de l'intégralité des
données biométriques je vous remercie
merci mes chers collègues dans la suite
discussion générale la parole est à
monsieur Jean-Jacques yes pour 12
minutes vous avez la parole moi j'ai un
collègue
uses
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
mes chers collègues monsieur le
Président rapporteur et l'auteur de la
proposition parce que je crois qu'il
faut
dire que le travail a été bien fait
alors
ce soir on va s'occuper d'innovation
on va dire principe de précaution mais
il faut laisser l'innovation
là on dit il y a de beaucoup
d'innovations mais il faut prendre un
peu des précautions
c'est comme ça sur ah on dit c'est très
bien d'ailleurs on nous a dit tout à
l'heure que c'était des milliers
d'emplois c'était le pétrole du 22e
c'est au 21e siècle
à voir avoir toutes ces techniques
nouvelles je pense que ça permet d'avoir
une avance technologique notamment en
France mais c'est quand même pas
je pense pas que ça soit aussi
en matière d'emploi aussi important que
on veut bien le dire
alors cette proposition de loi dont il
faut féliciter l'auteur et puis notre
rapporteur à qui tient aussi à rendre
hommage
c'est vrai que développement des
techniques biométriques doivent beaucoup
au développement de l'informatique
bien qu'en réalité quand on dit
détective géométriques elles existent
depuis longtemps
les photographies c'est une technique
biométrique les empreintes digitales
elles n'ont pas attendu l'informatique
mais bien sûr la reconnaissance
biométrique automatique ou dynamique ça
c'est tout à fait nouveau et ça nous
questionne aujourd'hui sur toutes les
incidences que selon comporte pour le
protection des droits fondamentaux et
notamment l'a dit la protection de la
vie privée
et monsieur le
rapporteur vous êtes un expert dans le
domaine en a eu des débats précédents
sur les fichiers publics
les cartes d'identité etc rappelez-vous
quand même le combat de la commission
des lois
alors
la jurisprudence est bien sûr rappelée
ce qui était la
nécessité de protéger cette vie privée
en rappelant les éléments qui peuvent
s'y rattacher le domicile l'image la
voie l'état de santé et la tribus du
corps humain etc et donc dans le cas de
la collecte du traitement à
l'utilisation de données biométriques
pour instaurer un contrôle d'identité
nous pouvons ainsi identifier
actuellement trois risques susceptibles
de porter atteinte à la vie privée un
risque au moment de la collecte
la teinte résulte de l'absence de
consentement de la personne lorsque
celui-ci constitue une condition légale
de la collecte d'information un risque
au moment du traitement des informations
c'est le cas lorsque le contenu des
fichiers sera usurpé et un risque au
moment de l'utilisation lorsque le
dispositif met en oeuvre une biométrie à
trace chacun laisse des traces de ses
empreintes plus ou moins exploitables
alors la proposition de loi que vous
nous soumettez
entendons limiter le recours à la
collecte et au traitement des données
biométriques aux fin de contrôle
l'identité pour renforcer la protection
du droit au respect de la vie privée en
ne parlons pas de l'article 2 puisque
c'est l'adaptation que il faut bien une
phase transitoire comme des choses ont
été autorisées et ensuite il faut bien
passer mais l'article 1 constitue la
substance de cette proposition et il
comporte deux avancées sur lequel
j'aimerais revenir le renforcement de la
doctrine de la CNIL consacrée à
l'encadrement des contrôles biométriques
d'identité et la suppression de la
biométrie dite de confort il convient en
ce qui concerne la doctrine de la CNIL
de préciser que les conditions de
recours à la biométrie causées par
proposition de loi pour procéder un
contrôle identité il y en quelque sorte
donner une valeur législative à la
doctrine de la CNIL
dans une fiche pratique du 12 décembre
2012 consacré à la biométrie sur les
lieux de travail l'acné le rappelle que
l'autorisation d'utiliser la biométrie
dite à trace ne peut être délivrée qu'à
plusieurs conditions et notamment la
finalité du dispositif
à la proportionnalité et à la sécurité
et bien entendu l'information des
personnes concernées c'est les quatre
conditions fixées par la CNIL et en
précisant la notion de strict nécessité
de sécurité la commission des lois
propose très justement procéder à droit
constant donnant ainsi une véritable
force à la doctrine et au travail
engagée par la CNIL en ce qui concerne
la biométrie dite de confort
lorsqu'une demande d'autorisation lui
est adressée la CNIL fixe actuellement
des exigences plus ou moins élevés en
fonction des finalités du dispositif
envisagé
dans le cas de la biométrie sécurité la
mise en oeuvre d'un dispositif
biométrique apparaît comme indispensable
pour répondre à une contrainte de
sécurité physique ou logique d'un
organisme
dès lors l'utilisation du dispositif
biométrique sera exclusive et les
personnes concernées par la contrôle
devront s'y soumettre pour la biométrie
de services affilié du dispositif
envisage et double elle vise la sécurité
de site ou la protection d'information
sensible la recherche d'une ergonomie
d'utilisation dans ce second cas
l'impératif de sécurité n'est pas
stricte il s'agit donc d'un dispositif
alternatif au dispositifiométrique et
doit donc nécessairement être proposé
aux utilisateurs
la proposition de loi
pour la biométrie de service on peut
douter en effet
de la valeur notamment du consentement
des usagers
dans quelle mesure peut-on fuser de se
soumettre à des contrôles biométriques
qui ne seraient qui se serait généralisé
dans une entreprise de surcroît on peut
aisément convenir qu'en réduisant les
possibilités de recours à la biométrie
nous diminuons de fait des risques de
dispersion des informations personnelles
il y a donc avec tous ces éléments une
véritable avancée donc il faut se
féliciter dans l'encadrement de la
biométrie et donc je souhaite à nouveau
saluer le travail effectué par le
rapporteur qui attire notre attention
sur les limites du texte de telle façon
qu'après avoir dégagé les éléments de
nature avancés sur cette question il
nous ouvre des perspectives de réfection
en vue d'un projet de loi annoncé sur
les libertés numériques
je tiens à rappeler tout d'abord que la
proposition de loi s'inscrit dans le
cadre de la loi du 6 janvier 78
ce qui exclut de son application les
traitements de données biométrique mais
en oeuvre par responsable de traitement
pour l'exercice d'activité
exclusivement personnelle je pense qu'il
faut le rappeler toujours ça
il faut donc s'attendre à ce que le
législateur
soit nouveau sollicité dès lors que le
recueil d'informations bien réalisé avec
le consentement des intéressés soulève
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
questions notamment quand on droit le
droit l'oubli
aux droits de propriété ou là encore
doit au respect de la vie privée
il faut également rappeler comme le fait
très justement le rapport que cette
proposition de loi si elle est adoptée
devrait aller en principe de pair avec
un renforcement des pouvoirs de la CNIL
dans le cadre du contrôle a priorité
qu'elle exerce ce rapport souligne que
depuis 2006 le nombre de contrôles
rapportés au nombre total d'autorisation
délivrée par la CNIL sur la même période
c'est vérification est porté sur 4,5%
des dispositifs uniquement
il est alors sous-entendu que cette
organisme aura besoin de moyens humains
supplémentaires pour effectuer plus
largement sa mission nous sommes là dans
un domaine plein d'incertitudes
notamment parce que la perspective du
règlement européen semble indiquer que
nous irons probablement vers une
suppression des autorisations préalables
au profit d'un contrôle à posteriori et
dans ce cas là il faudra quand même qui
est un renforcement des contrôles
outre ces remarques je crois pouvoir
dire en conclusion qu'il existe un
consensus important sur l'adoption de ce
texte
grâce notamment au large travail de
réflexion
engagé depuis longtemps parce que il y a
eu plusieurs travaux par la commission
des lois pour cerner le sujet et en ce
qui concerne le droit européen
on n'a pas beaucoup parlé pendant les
élections européennes enfin c'est quand
même important d'en parler de temps en
temps la France est quand même plutôt en
pointe c'est question là et plutôt
moteur il faut que nous continuions
tant en ce qui concerne le Conseil de
l'Europe que l'Union européenne il faut
vraiment que nous soyons en point pour
la protection des libertés publiques
nous souhaitons donc instaurer
progressivement le cas législatif le
mieux adapté à la protection de la vie
privée de nos concitoyens nous avons
conscience qu'il restera encore à faire
mais c'était une étape indispensable vu
égard au développement exponentiel de
ces techniques biométrique bien entendu
le groupe UMP votre à la proposition de
loi amender
avec aussi l'amendement du Gouvernement
tout ça c'est c'est des améliorations de
texte et la finalité est toujours la
même et je crois que nous pouvons nous
féliciter de ce point de vue
de l'unanimité du Sénat sur ces
questions là la protection de la vie
privée des données personnelles je pense
que beaucoup de sociétés nous enviraient
si elles arrivaient à faire la même
chose
merci mes chers collègues dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole est
à monsieur Jean-Yves Leconte pour 5
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la biométrie c'est
vieux comme le monde mais comme la
signaler notre collègue Virginie Claisse
c'est les progrès de l'informatique qui
permettent de traiter ces données
l'évolution qui permet de passer de
données traçable prise à l'insu d'un
individu qui se multiplie qui rend
aujourd'hui cette question de la
biométrie et de son usage
particulièrement d'actualité aussi je
pense en particulier à la reconnaissance
faciale qui grâce aux nouveaux
algorithmes devient quelque chose qui
conjuguait aux caméras de surveillance
permet effectivement de réelles
atteintes à la vie privée alors préciser
les finalités de l'usage de la biométrie
c'est particulièrement opportun et comme
le président yest le soulignait cela
fait partie des combats du Sénat et de
sa commission des lois depuis longtemps
et quel que soit sa majorité les
tentative parfois de gouvernement
d'aller plus loin je pense à la carte
d'identité biométrique ou à la manière
dont on envisageait le recueil des
empreintes pour le fichier des
passeports ont été à chaque fois bloqués
par notre dispositif juridique le
Conseil constitutionnel dans le cas de
la carte d'identité le Conseil d'État
dans l'autre mais il est vrai que compte
tenu des évolutions technologiques il
était important aujourd'hui et je salue
une initiative de notre collègue Gaëtan
Goff de s'interroger sur les usages
autorisés pour la biométrie toutefois
il me semble indispensable après
avoir indiqué ça que finalement les
protections que nous pouvons donner à
nos concitoyens dans ce domaine de son
pas certaine dans la mesure où bien
entendu toutes ces données circulent
dans tous les sens au-delà des
frontières c'est bien la nature de la
société de l'information et de la
circulation de ces données par delà les
frontières et par conséquent aucune
protection totale sans maîtrise de
l'innovation et sans un certain nombre
de règlement non seulement européens
mais internationaux vous avez signalé
madame la ministre ce qui s'était passé
en Afrique mais bien évidemment que si
nous voulons protéger
notre
nos données personnelles et les
questions de liberté individuelle en
France
ce n'est pas lorsqu'il y a une élection
en Afrique que d'un seul coup il faut
inciter un fichier biométrique de
l'ensemble d'une population parce que là
on va contre nos propres valeurs et ça a
été quand même de temps en temps des
tentatives qui ont eu lieu de la même
manière un français en voyage un
français
elle peut se trouver face à d'autres
législations qui par le biais
d'externalisation de l'état dans lequel
on se place retrouvent se retrouvent par
le biais de société privée utilisée en
France je pense aussi à la manière dont
nous exploitons un certain nombre de
fichiers à grève 2 Eurock maintenant le
fichier vice européen si nous souhaitons
que nos concitoyens soient respectés
dans leur vie privée il convient de
faire la même chose pour l'ensemble des
étrangers qui viennent sur le territoire
de l'espace Schengen enfin quelques
quelques remarques complémentaires sur
ce qui se passe en termes
d'externalisation des visas ensuite de
ce que j'indiquais tout à l'heure nous
exenions de plus en plus les demandes de
visa à l'étranger il convient de ce
point de vue là de se poser la question
de la bonne protection de ces données à
cette occasion il y a aussi des usages
de la biométrie où il faudrait être un
peu plus audacieux je pense en
particulier au Passeport qu'on délivre
aux Français à l'étranger qui mériterait
plus de coopération entre les pays
Schengen de manière à ce que entre pays
Schengen les biométries soient
compatibles et les visas puissent être
les passeports puissent être demandés
dans d'autres classes que les consulats
français mais partout dans tous les
consulats de l'espace Schengen je pense
aussi aux certificat de nationalité
française qui pourrait être
utile s'ils étaient biométrisés dans la
mesure où ça permettrait de nombreux
d'éviter de nombreuses suspicions de
fraude à l'identité bref sur ce point il
n'y aura pas de protection de totale
s'il n'y a pas de d'échanges entre notre
pays et les autres pays du monde dans
une coopération européenne donc sans
respect en France d'aussi du droit des
étrangers enfin vous l'avez évoqué
madame la ministre c'est vrai que
la balanisation de l'usage de la
biométrie pour les plus jeunes est un
danger pour eux la société il faut bien
avoir conscience des risques que cela
peut comporter rien ne se fera bien
entendu sans un cadre national approprié
et c'est bien le sens de cette
proposition de loi qui est tout à fait
adéquate mais je vais aussi dire une
chose pour pouvoir maîtriser
les contraintes juridiques que nous
souhaitons pour protéger les Français et
les personnes qui habitent sur notre
territoire il faut une maîtrise
technologique sans maîtrise
technologique il n'y aura pas de
capacité de faire respecter la loi et
par conséquent ça implique aussi
de favoriser l'innovation par des
sociétés françaises enfin cette PPL bien
sûr le groupe socialiste lavotra elle
est en parfaite cligne avec des combats
du Sénat ou nous l'avons souligné elle
précise les finalités de l'usage de la
biométrie elle est donc particulièrement
utile et le souligne la mobilisation du
Sénat sur cette question mais ce vote
n'aura d'utilité que dans un cadre où le
gouvernement portera les les
préoccupations du Sénat au niveau
européen et où nous aurons une société
européenne qui aura vocation et qui aura
mobilisé pour défendre l'identité et la
l'intégrité de l'ensemble des Européens
dans le monde et cela passe par la
réciprocité je vous remercie merci mon
cher collègue
bien la discussion générale et close
nous passons donc à la discussion du
texte de la commission je suis saisi
deux amendements un amendement numéro 1
du gouvernement madame la ministre si
vous voulez bien le présenter
merci monsieur le Président l'amendement
que le Gouvernement a souhaité déposer
d'abord montre notre intérêt quant à la
question qui était examinée ce jour
ainsi que le souhait de nourrir le débat
que le sénateur Gorce a voulu porter au
centre de cette assemblée par cette
amendement le Gouvernement a souhaité
clarifier deux points du texte retenu
dans sa version finale par la commission
des lois d'abord clarifier la finalité
de sécurité pour laquelle ces techniques
biométriques pourrait continuer à être
utilisé le texte présenté aujourd'hui
propose en effet deux types de finalité
d'une part le contrôle d'accès physique
ou logique d'autre part la protection
des personnes des biens et des données
le présent amendement vise à clarifier
que c'est bien cette finalité de
sécurité la protection des personnes des
biens et des données qu'il faut ici
viser l'objectif est aussi de s'assurer
que la loi n'interdit pas certains
usages comme par exemple
l'authentification d'un paiement par
biométrie ensuite l'amendement visa à
répondre à l'objectif de limiter le
recours à la biométrie au cas pour
lesquels elle est nécessaire en
proposant une rédaction alternative plus
facilement utilisable et par le juge et
par l'acnil qui lorsqu'elle recourt à
des autorisations doit pouvoir utiliser
des outils pertinents conformes aux
outils qu'elle utilise habituellement et
doit aussi recourir à des outils plus
nouveaux comme celui de l'analyse des
risques qui pèsent sur les données
personnelles qui est un outil que le
gouvernement encourage la CNIL à
utiliser donc voilà un amendement qui
modifie à la marge le sens du texte qui
est proposé mais qui en affine la
définition juridique
pour répondre à des à des préoccupations
de de
clarté de la loi
de monsieur le rapporteur
Président si vous me le permettez madame
la ministre nous joindrons la discussion
sur l'amendement du Gouvernement et le
sous-amendement présenté que je présente
tout d'abord avant de développer
des bas notre argumentation sur cet
amendement je voulais vous
acter de choses qui nous rapprochent un
regret et un accord un regret c'est
effectivement le fait que lundi n'est
pas été n'est pas fournie son avis mais
ce n'est pas la faute du rapporteur ni
de la commission des lois puisqu'elle
n'a pas répondu à la demande que je lui
avais fait d'audition c'est un regret
donc que nous partageons l'accord c'est
celui sur la création d'un groupe de
réflexion que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure je m'en réjouis je pense que le
Sénat se réjouit fait de cette
proposition dont je souhaite d'ailleurs
compte tenu des textes qui vont venir à
l'étude bientôt qu'il ne se résume pas
dans le temps à celui de la navette
parlementaire mais là encore nous sommes
parfaitement d'accord alors en ce qui
concerne maintenant un autre point qui a
été redit à plusieurs reprises en
particulier de notre collègue Esther
Benbassa il s'agit pas de freiner par la
proposition de loi telle qu'elle va je
suppose être voté tout à l'heure
l'initiative économique
industrielle et l'ingénierie en ce
domaine
si on quitte
cette immense progrès qui est la
biométrie dans notre civilisation
actuelle pour prendre un autre exemple
un essor considérable de l'humanité est
intervenue non pas lorsqu'on a créé la
roue mais lorsqu'on a inventé l'écriture
lorsqu'on a inventé l'écriture on a
inventé la lettre anonyme on n'a pas mis
un terme à l'écriture sous prétexte
qu'il existait la lettre anonyme c'est
un usage de l'écriture l'écriture permet
de publier des livres aux idées
repoussantes dans ces cas-là on interdit
le livre on n'interdit pas l'écriture
donc c'est l'usage auquel nous apportons
des limites dans le texte et ces usages
nous les apportons nous les limitons
dans le cadre de ce que sont le principe
du socle de notre société ce faisant
nous n'interdisons absolument pas les
progrès techniques dans toutes les
autres usages autorisés alors j'en viens
donc à l'amendement puisque précisément
les amendements donner limite les usages
dans des conditions qui sont à la fois
souples et précise alors je dois dire
que
l'amendement du Gouvernement
fait suite à une réflexion qui a été la
nôtre après l'élaboration du texte de la
commission des lois effectivement je
conçois et peut-être d'ailleurs le
président de la commission y a-t-il pour
quelque chose que la rédaction qui ait
été qui a été proposée était un peu
croustillant et qu'il fallait y apporter
je le prends comme tel et qu'il fallait
y apporter une simplification j'avais
donc prévu de déposer un amendement que
j'ai communiqué au gouvernement il y a
quelques jours il y a deux jours et sur
la base de cet amendement vous vous avez
vous-même présenté celui que vous dont
vous venez de nous donner lecture or il
se trouve que je n'avais plus dès lors à
présenter
du rendement que je voulais
donner ce matin à la commission des lois
puisque l'amendement du Gouvernement
reprend pour l'essentiel les éléments du
texte de la commission en particulier le
caractère cumulatif des deux conditions
auxquelles nous sommes très attachés et
la finalité de sécurité que vous
définissez comme je vous cite la
protection de l'intégrité physique des
personnes la protection des biens ou la
protection d'information dont la
divulgation le détournement ou la
destruction porterait un préjudice grave
et réversible vous gardez les deux
commissions le texte est affiné dans le
sens où nous le souhaitons le faire tout
cela nous va parfaitement vous supprimez
un certain nombre de points dans
l'exception dans l'expression pardon
contrôle de l'accès physique ou logique
à des locaux équipement applications au
service le texte est allégé sans perdre
encore une fois son objectif et ça
signification la commission des lois
elle a donc il reste juste un petit
point qui explique le sous amendement
que je présente qui est un point
purement rédactionnel par lequel nous
passons d'une rédaction en quelque sorte
négative à une rédaction positive pour y
intégrer la nécessité excédant l'intérêt
propre de l'organisme sous cette réserve
le moment du gouvernement est
effectivement accepté et c'est un avis
favorable que je donne dans ton nom
personnel quand celui unanime de la
commission des lois si mon cher collègue
donc il faudra de la Commission se
réserve de votre activité sous un moment
la vie du gouvernement sur le sous
amendement madame le ministre
oui je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur pour votre lecture de
l'amendement présenté par le
gouvernement celui que vous vous
proposez il s'agit de remplacer le ne se
limitant pas aux besoins par excédent
l'intérêt propre vous réintroduisez ce
faisant la notion d'intérêt propre de
l'organisme la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement n'avait pas souhaité
conserver cette notion d'intérêt propre
c'est d'abord parce qu'elle elle n'est
pas définie en droit et c'est aussi
parce que le recours à l'usage de la
biométrie peut parfois être
utile même lorsque
l'intérêt de l'organisme est dépassé
lorsqu'il touche par exemple l'usager
lui-même voire je donnais l'exemple des
des transactions commerciales avec
paiement authentifié par un lecteur de
données biométrique et bien dans ce cas
c'est de l'intérêt du consomm
consommateurs d'avoir sa transaction
sécurisée le plus possible sans pour
autant qu'elle soit stockée au fichier
ou quoi que ce soit puisque la donnée
biométrique est seulement contenue dans
le support qui est utilisé et mais c'est
aussi l'intérêt de l'économie en général
que d'avoir des marchés le plus sécurisé
possible c'est la raison pour laquelle
le gouvernement était réticent à l'usage
de cette notion et que c'est dans
l'intérêt propre je crois que ce sont
des discussions que nous continuerons à
avoir je vous remercie d'avoir accepté
d'avoir rattrapé au vol ma suggestion de
créer un groupe de travail c'est un
engagement sérieux de la part du
gouvernement qui va au-delà du
calendrier législatif qui pour le moment
n'est pas précisé concernant le projet
de loi numérique pour cette raison le
gouvernement souhaite faire sagesse sur
votre sous amendement
merci donc je vais mettre au bois Le
sous amendement numéro 2 qui est qq un
avis de sagesse du gouvernement est-ce
qu'il y a des explications de vote
je n'en vois pas ceux qui sont
favorables sur un moment veulent bien de
montrer en levant la main
merci il est donc adopté
l'amendement numéro 1 du gouvernement
sous la vie favorable de la commission
des lois ce qui sont favorables bien
lever la main
l'amendement est donc adopté pour
l'article 1 c'est qu'ils sont favorables
à cette attitude bellever la main merci
l'article 2 je suis donc à l'amendement
ceux qui sont favorables d'article 2
veulent bien lever la main merci je vais
donc mettre au volant
d'explication de vote je n'envoie pas je
mets donc on voit l'ensemble de cette
proposition c'est qu'ils sont favorables
bien lever la main
et donc adopter
voilà pour l'adoption de cette
proposition de loi socialiste qui vise à
limiter l'utilisation des techniques
biométriques à une nécessité de sécurité
un texte qui a donc obtenu l'adhésion
dessinateur mais qui a encore de
nombreux détracteurs notamment dans le
monde du numérique certains spécialistes
craignent quand tel texte soit un frein
au développement des entreprises de la
biométrie un secteur actuellement en
pleine expansion en France vous pouvez
toujours voir et revoir toutes les
séances sur notre site sur public
sénat.fr très bonne fin de journée sur
les chaînes parlementaires